[Music]
hey guys ready let's have some fun
all right I know we're at the end of the
second day of next some y'all look kind
of exhausted I can see it but just chill
have some fun we're gonna be doing some
Ruby today so that's got to be fun right
you guys alright so welcome thank you
for coming to our Ruby talk this is
Google cloud platform loves Ruby cuz we
do and hopefully after this hour that'll
become quite clear alright so before we
get started I just want to get a sense
of you guys who here is a ruby developer
can I just get out really quick all
right awesome it's what I was hoping but
how about who here has used Ruby with
Google cloud on cloud okay sweet
hopefully we'll get you guys started
there is our show of hands all right so
hey my name is Remy Taylor I'm a
developer programs engineer for Google
cloud and of course I'm a rubyist I've
been doing Ruby at Google for C I'm
about to be at Google for five years and
I've been doing Ruby full-time for
almost four so actually at Google we do
a whole lot of Ruby that's not always
obvious to people but we do and we're
really passionate about it and we love
it so in Google cloud in particular we
found a lot of really passionate great
Ruby engineers and we brought them
together to make what we're calling
ourselves the Ruby cloud team so at
Google Cloud we're always deploying our
own rails applications our own Ruby web
applications and interact with the API
so whenever this friction or something
that could be a little bit better we're
usually the first to see it and kind of
selfishly for ourselves we want to make
that experience awesome and we love to
share it with y'all so what I want to
talk about today is I want to show you
guys how you can get up and running with
Ruby on cloud looks like that'll be good
for a lot of y'all as well as how to
bring a lot of our products into your
applications to empower them with Google
cloud platform services so if you
haven't noticed or the
two days GCP has a whole lot of products
no I didn't try and fit them all on the
screen I don't even know all of them but
a lot of these provide really useful of
really powerful and awesome api's so the
question I had that I wanted to try and
answer with you guys today
is how easily can we use those products
from Ruby so let's take a quick look I
don't let you guys be the judge of that
so one of the amazing things we've been
working on it's one of my personal
favorite things is we've been putting
together a number of client libraries
for some of our great api's these are
hosted on github you can find them right
now under our Google cloud platform
organization check out a lot of things
there you can find them under the Google
cloud Ruby repo if you go to this
website you'll actually find we've got
amazing API references to help you get
started a lot of good little guides and
Doc's but of course right now let's just
jump in and try something ourselves so I
just picked the product let's try and
say hello world
to cloud storage and see what that
experience looks like so as a ruby
developer you're probably first gonna
try and find Oh nope nope let's look at
search so hopefully you guys have seen
the cloud console now a bunch of times
throughout the day and in cloud storage
in the cloud console we've got this file
browser right and you can find any of
your files listed under buckets which is
how we organize our files there right
now I made a bucket called my cat
pictures and sadly it's empty so what
we'll do for this hello world is we'll
fix that
so now as Ruby developers usually the
first thing we want to do is install
some kind of a gem so we're going to use
Google Cloud storage we'll install the
Google Cloud Storage gem when we open up
our fresh new Ruby file and we're ready
to go what we're going to require then
is Google Cloud storage
first thing we want is some kind of a
service object right we want something
that we can
to call storage and so that again we
just kind of instantiate an instance of
Google Cloud storage to talk to it
hopefully you're seeing a pattern here
when we want to upload to this
particular bucket we do a similar thing
so we need a reference to this Google
Cloud Storage bucket so we just ask
storage hey can we get the mic at
pictures bucket at that point you're
already ready to add a new file to
storage really easy on top of that
bucket we'll just add a new file and
assuming you have a local file called
images my cat ping thats all you need to
do although you know personally I'm a
rails developer and though the word new
file can be a little bit confusing to me
I'm used a new meaning instantiating a
new object it's not clear to me whether
or not this really creates the file on
cloud storage so personally I'm gonna
roll with the crate file
alias for this although you know I've
got a web application where we upload a
lot of these users a lot of these users
uploads so if you want to maybe I like
the semantics of upload file better if
there are Rubeus in the audience you
know there's one thing we can never
agree on is how to name things so in
typical Ruby fashion cuz Rubeus develop
these libraries we alias a bunch of
things where appropriate
so we'll see a bunch of fun little ruby
isms because that's kind of how we roll
as we go through these libraries but
most importantly any one of these lines
of code does the same thing what it
gives us is if we plot back into the
console we'll see we've got our my cat
image and that's the most important
thing so of course this is just one of
lots of libraries for interacting with
lots of great products if you follow
this website and you install google
cloud what you'll get is a ton of these
libraries for a bunch of different
products so that you can go ahead open
up IRB or something start requiring
Google Cloud Storage Google Cloud
datastore etc but really this is just a
big umbrella package if you go to Google
cloud on rubygems you'll see really this
just has a ton of
different dependencies on a lot of our
other libraries so that's great
especially when you want to try things
out but really in your own applications
you don't want to download all of that
so you can pick and choose so in your
gem file for your rails app or whatever
it may be just add Google Cloud Storage
or Google cloud pub/sub and whatever you
may want to use so when you get back
home when you get back to your hotel
tonight cuz hopefully this would be
really exciting you want to try it out
and you want to try and remember all the
things we're talking about today like
remember how did she say I can get back
up and running the one thing I want you
guys to leave here with today is to
remember to pull up our documentation
our Doc's in my opinion for our cloud
products pretty awesome and in
particular for getting up and running
with these client libraries there's a
wonderful client libraries page it may
be hard to see up here on this slide but
it has enough to get you up and running
it has everything you need if you forget
everything else so if you find that
client libraries page it's gonna be
impossible to see everything up here
just on this slide but it only has a
couple things it has the gem that you
need to install for that product it has
the command you need to run on your
local computer to authenticate so that
you'll be able to talk to that API and
it also has a link out to the Google
Cloud SDK which were used for
authentication and we'll touch on that
later third there's a code snippet you
should be able to just copy and paste
this into one of your Ruby files into
IRB replace a placeholder and it'll let
you prove that you're up and ready to go
it kind of got cut off on the bottom of
the slide here but actually I'm only
missing about a lion I could almost fit
it these are really really really teeny
simple snippets and finally under all of
that it's got a link for everything
you'll need it's got a link to the API
documentation and reference for this
finally worth pointing out I know I'm
spending a lot of time on this slide but
if you didn't notice I've got Ruby
highlighted but next to it is also
Python PHP no GS Java go c-sharp now I
want you guys to all
use rupee because it's awesome and we've
been putting a lot of work into this but
if you want to do the same thing with
any of these other languages the exact
same information is there what you need
to download in terms of a package how to
authenticate etc and I know for a lot of
shops the reality is maybe you have a
rails back-end but you're doing some
node.js on the front end and it's really
powerful to be able to use a similar
client library to talk to either of them
okay so real quick should give you a
sense of what these libraries are like I
want to show you just a couple more
samples you can kind of get the look and
feel of these we're gonna talk to
datastore datastore is one of Google's
no sequel databases and it gets started
of course like before we're just gonna
require our Google Cloud datastore we
need a datastore service will
instantiate that up and then we want to
insert kind of a row in datastore those
are entities so I'm gonna make a dog and
then kind of a typical Ruby idiom that
you'd see when I make that I want to set
a bunch of properties on it so for my
dog I'll set a name and I'll set a breed
this case my dog's name it breed is
goofball cuz he is a bit of a goofball
and then I just need to add that to
datastore easy right and kind of
idiomatic so reason blocks again we use
these products and we use the libraries
all the time so as Rubeus when something
doesn't feel right
we go in and kind of make it look like
we would expect it to in any other
library and then just finally I mean
when you want to query for these things
this should be query syntax that you're
probably familiar with and I've seen and
some libraries that use sequel databases
for example all query for all dogs who
are goofballs I'll get all the goofs and
then I'll just loop through them
normally just normal Ruby cloud speech
is really fun if you guys haven't
already looked at our machine learning
api's speech natural language
translation vision I kind of recommend
you stop what you're doing now and look
those up like hopefully watch the rest
of this presentation but there show so
cool they're really awesome going to
show
just a couple little snippets but here's
one of the reasons why I love this
okay so speech we'll take an audio file
and it'll just return the text from the
audio file very complicated lots of
machine learning they're all networks I
don't even know all I know is as a
rubyist these are the five lines of code
for if you don't include the require
that you need to do this so again
require Google Cloud speech we'll get an
instance of a client library like a
service we tell speech that this is our
local audio file in this case we have a
local audio draw file and then all we do
is we call recognizer on that file then
if we print it out that gives us the
transcript it's really really powerful
things going on in just a couple of
lines of really really simple ripping
translation it's about the exact same
thing really powerful require service
when a translate a bit of text from one
language to another
how goes it to french como so that easy
bigquery is really cool lets you query
over ginormous amounts of data really
really quickly
they're a bunch of blog posts that some
people have been writing about even
processing the entirety of the github
public data set and people been using
bigquery to do really interesting things
definitely Google for this if you
haven't like processing every ruby gem
file in every public repository on
github and even pursing it to see what
libraries people are using super cool
one of my favorite things that we made
for our DSL here is when we were making
bigquery tables for ourselves so we have
data sets and they have tables when we
are calling the API and using the
low-level API to make these things it
felt a little bit wrong as Rubeus we're
used to defining schemas in sequel
databases so for anyone who's done rails
specifically like active record or
someone who's used the sequel gem to
generate schemas this should look really
really really familiar to you we use the
idiom
DSL for creating schemas that you would
anywhere else and finally one other like
thing that I thought was a cool idea m--
just because it's something that we
didn't think of initially that we were
going to add but then as we started
using the library and talking to the
service it may not be a sense so for
logging logging is a really great API
you can call it to send your log data to
logs are associated with particular
Google cloud platform resources like a
Google App Engine application in this
instance but what I find interesting is
actually what we did here so if you're
rubyist you've probably used the Ruby
standard library logger class right we
use it everywhere typically if I made a
library maybe you'd be able to pass in a
Ruby logger that's just an a Ruby logger
they all at the same API and then I
would use that to print out any of my
messages well when we were using logging
we thought well that really in my
application that's all I want
I want a Ruby logger so in this if you
call logging dot logger what that
actually gives you back easy Ruby logger
that responds to all the same methods as
a standard library one so of course we
are calling logger dot info job started
but all of those different methods
everything that a logger supports this
does as well so it can just be a drop-in
replacement that makes it really easy
for you these are the types of things
that I love that we've been doing all
their products click through them
they're fun I love this DSL
now DNS really cool that you can manage
your DNS records from code but also just
look at this I mean just at a quick
glance you can probably get a sense of
what this is doing and of course it just
again has the simple require at the top
it's got it needs to make the service
but then after that is just doing a
bunch of record updates within a zone
great DSL you can see we're adding an a
record we're removing a text record and
we're replacing some MX records
something that I know I spent a lot of
time in the UIs and like
my name space my like DNS servers doing
so knowing I can do it and do it this
easily in code it's really really cool
in my opinion go check out the machine
learning api's if you wanted to just
start playing with vision I wish I could
honestly give a full presentation on
vision it's that fun and that exciting
this little itsy-bitsy slide small
enough amount of code that I can make
the text real big require vision stand
[ __ ] the service tell it that we have
this local image file and then oh you do
the magic line here is towards the
bottom image dot labels all you have to
do as a ruby developer is called image
dot labels and that will give you back a
list of things that the vision API had
detected and found in your MN show if
it's an image of a cat
maybe cat mammal the type of cat which I
don't even know but the vision API does
television if it sees in the background
it's really really powerful and awesome
so that was a lot sorry for that but
hopefully you're starting to see a
pattern here my goal is to allow you
guys to go back and have a sense of what
the experience is like using these
libraries so that you can get up and
running really quickly and easily and
also remember the code is open source
and it's up on github so issues are
welcome feedback is welcome definitely
thank you to everyone out there who has
already been a great contributor has
been giving us great feedback the
community has been really really
wonderful and really receptive for this
and we appreciate it and if you remember
one last thing when you get home if you
don't remember any of this just remember
go to our Doc's this one page will get
you up and running with pretty much
everything you need all right for anyone
who doesn't know this is a musical rest
note I use it for my water it's a
quarter rest for anyone who doesn't read
music I always still
before I show you this next part I want
to just briefly take you back in time I
want to take you back to 2009 now 2009
was a pretty interesting year for ruby
ruby version 191 was released this is
important because it was the first
stable version of ruby 1-9 and this
brought us all kinds of new things this
gave us an entirely new Ruby interpreter
yarv as opposed to the MRI that we had
been using previously and there's lots
of things that if you're newer to ruby
and you didn't experience the 180th
series you might not know came through
this things like the new hash syntax
where you don't need to use a hash
rocket for anything the arrow shorthand
for generating lam does lots of cool
things basic object all these things are
really really cool
187 was what we had been on for years at
this time and it was a big enough change
that it took a lot of us years and years
and years way past oh nine it's actually
fully migrated our apps got us where we
are today and interestingly rails to
three rails to three was one of the most
exciting releases for me because it was
the first release of rails that was
built entirely on rack so before that
it's almost hard to imagine if you're
familiar with rack before that rails had
its own layers for things like dealing
with CGI fast CGI and like all the under
kind of survery bits so this was super
super cool so it also got to introduce
rails engines rails metal and just for a
bit of context things like the Aral
engine for active record for anyone
who's familiar or even the bundler
integration that comes with rails today
those things weren't part of this those
things came way after well that's
interesting
cool a little bit of history but why am
i interested in 2009 what does this
matter
well it's actually just interesting
really to me because I gave a talk back
in 2009 and it was the first time I gave
a talk on using Ruby with Google App
Engine so really it was my fur
version of this talk it was my first
talk on Ruby on Google Cloud and of
course at the time it was using JRuby we
didn't have Ruby running on App Engine
like we do today we shall talk about
more but we did have Java so I could
make it work
now when I was thinking about today's
talk I remembered this and I actually
went back and I dug through and I found
my old slides this is actually my old
title slide and just remaster it a
little bit and I found it interesting
that I did this eight years ago
my main thought was was why me and I'm
talking you today about we're gonna look
at Ruby on App Engine and I was
wondering why even eight years ago was
that so exciting for me I answered that
in the talk I gave a number of years ago
so here's the answer of why eight years
ago I started playing with Ruby on App
Engine and gave talks about it because
of the magic it's so magical back when I
learned about App Engine it seems like
crazy black magic how it worked
I liked to quote something that I
believe this quote was on the App Engine
homepage and it is App Engine uses
multiple web servers to run your
application and automatically adjust the
number of servers it's using to handle
requests reliably at the time that was
there was crazy that was an it was
amazing I mean my personal deployment
system in O nine was basically like a
bunch of wires taped together and
managed by Capistrano scripts which in
fairness is kind of cool I was really
really proud of my Capistrano scripts
but when it came to things like scaling
like what if all of a sudden thousands
of people hit my app tomorrow or my
clients app when I saw App Engine it
seemed like magic it seemed like the
perfect thing especially when I was
doing like I was a consultant I'd make a
rails application I want to hand it off
and kind of say hey you guys deal with
the scaling that takes too much time I
can't do that versus we could hand off
an app engine app and say yeah that'll
keep running
that's gonna vertically scale you'll be
fine yeah if you get a million requests
cause of some big PR release or
something tomorrow they'll be fine so
these are the things that really really
excited me about app engine then and
they still excite me about it today so
just for interest and to compare it to
today a little bit even though I was
running on JRuby which wasn't definitely
I wasn't the intended audience for a
pension at the time it was actually
surprisingly easy all you need to do
back then was sign up to try App Engine
for Java it's all the SDK for App Engine
for Java and you need a JRuby for local
development they had a tool it's great
it boot up an emulated environment of
App Engine so you had a way that you
could run your application locally and
for deployment one command one command
and take your application and put it up
on appspot comm awesome there were a
couple of like restrictions that you had
to deal with to get all of this magic
though there was no file right access I
believe it all like even if you needed
to touch a temp file I'm pretty sure
that was basically totally disabled
which made running a number of
frameworks and libraries actually
difficult which relied on saving
something real quick maybe temporarily
to the file system and a big one that I
remember really being challenging for me
was there's no relational database so
datastore which is wonderful on scales
amazingly it's just a completely new
concept so to someone who is used to
building things using relational sequel
databases really slowed me down those
have tried to learn these new concepts
and there are a number of other
limitations - well let's fast for it so
Ruby today for Google cloud platform
they're actually a ton of different
options if you want you can use compute
engine to have full control over your
environment if you want to manage your
own Linux Windows VMs and have complete
control that's great and we have that
today if you're already using docker
you may want to take a look at container
engine this is essentially google's
hosted version of kubernetes
and finally of course if you just want
to focus on your application like I did
and still do then you can use App Engine
and it still has all the magic today
that it had then so App Engine is
awesome if y'all didn't hear at the
keynote this morning
App Engine flexible environment which is
what Ruby runs on today just g8 this
morning which is super super exciting
for our team and in addition to Ruby it
runs a bunch of these other languages so
we Jade a bunch of languages on Google
App Engine today and it's great I love
it so you can run a number of the other
languages if you're using them in your
shop as well and of course for the Ruby
runtime the thing that's important to me
for Ruby on this new app engine is it
still has all that magic it still has
everything I loved about App Engine then
and I love about it now I make my
application and just let it go and just
kind of for fun just for a comparison
today without Benjen flex this is kind
of how it compares today you sign up for
Google cloud and you download and
install the Google Cloud SDK so these
are cloud wide now and the cloud SDK
gives you all kinds of tools and
utilities for interacting with and
managing products across cloud and
particularly great is you can bring any
Ruby version you want so you're not
locked down to this JRuby we'll get to
this later but any version of Ruby you
can run for local development whereas
before we ran a little emulator today to
locally develop your rails or Ruby web
application just rail server just use
your local tools as you use them today
totally completely the same there's
nothing App Engine specific in any of
your Ruby web applications just vanilla
regular Ruby app and we'll make it run
now if you are asking like hey Ronnie
but I know your production environment
it's gonna be a little bit different
than my local development workstation
what if I want to be a hundred percent
sure
and I want to run my app in the exact
same environment well because I benjin
flex is completely based on docker you
can do that if you want to um you can
use our same runtime and you can docker
run it locally we'll touch on that a
little bit later but for the most part
just do what you're doing it's awesome
and then for deploy the story is the
same it's just as magical and awesome
one command g-cloud op deploy will take
your application
put it up on appspot comm or your custom
doing the restrictions I got to strike
through all of these and one thing that
really made it a little bit more
challenging for me to use App Engine
eight years ago the lack of a relational
sequel database that's way different now
so today we've got fully managed sequel
databases on cloud sequel and also if
you didn't hear this in addition to my
sequel we now have postgrads available
and that will show up in the cloud
console to allow you to choose a
Postgres database real soon alright just
so that you know you guys can see how to
get up and running I just want to walk
through what you need all you're gonna
need to get your route you're like Ruby
and rails apps up on App Engine you need
a Google account sign up for a Google
account you need to sign in to Google
Cloud get into the console sign into
Google console you're gonna need to make
a new project if you haven't seen in all
the other talks that you've seen it next
most of the resources in Google cloud
are based around a project so here
whatever you name your project your
thing will deploy to my project
appspot.com
and you need the Cloud SDK hopefully
again you've been seeing this a lot
through a lot of your talks today this
gives us the g-cloud tool that we're
going to be using not only to deploy but
also it's the same tool that we wanted
earlier to authenticate our libraries so
this is really useful to have your gonna
want in once you've got all that just
from your applications directory just CD
into your rails app run g-cloud app
deploy and that should do it as soon as
you run that for me
Asian directory g-cloud is gonna say oh
I see this is a ruby application I know
how to deploy that would you like me to
continue and for rails applications and
most scenarios just keep hitting okay
and your Apple to play it will ask you
for a little boot command so if you're
doing something custom if you're using
Sinatra he needs to know how to run your
application where the file is but for
the most part just kick off your command
and it'll go her ring so that's awesome
and that's exciting and I definitely
recommend that you all continue to look
into app engine flex but what I'm really
interested in talking to you guys about
today or the things that we did and the
things that the Ruby cloud team learned
while developing this to make this
easier for ourselves and for you guys
challenges we ran up against when we
were trying to develop our own apps and
the first thing everyone needs to cover
and deal with its dependencies so of
course today you've probably got all of
your dependencies listed in a gem file
that's great and when you deploy will
bundle install that for you on the
server we do bundle install without your
development or or test dependencies
which is pretty typical in idiomatic but
that is something we ran into and we
were accidentally installing development
and dependencies when we were playing
around with our initial images so like
those kind of things that we've really
done are now done and ready with the
runtime and if for some reason you don't
want a gem file and you don't want to
use bundler for your dependencies you
actually don't need to this 13 line app
just uses web brick and it's one ruby
file and this will run properly on App
Engine flex without doing any
dependencies or anything it was actually
a user request that we got so thank you
for your feedback we've got it and it is
really really cool you can g-cloud app
deploy a single 13 line file without any
other information and this works when it
comes to dependencies any Rubeus you're
probably seeing this message
it's usually not a good one to see it
usually means the next couple hours of
my life might be dealing with local or
production development issues so usually
this happens when we are trying to
deploy and our production environment is
missing some of the negative
dependencies that are required for gems
that need to compile negative
dependencies for the most case we should
have this handled for you
so our Ruby runtime installs all the
dependencies needed for those most
common gems that we've run into this all
the time with development headers for my
sequel or sequel a or postgrads those
imagemagick dependencies that can be
hard to track down
things like XML to XSLT which you
usually need for nokogiri all these
things we've run into the pain ourselves
and so we've made sure that they're all
there and all handled for you if you
need to add something custom hopefully
you don't but if there's a package that
you're using that no other Ruby
developer would need it's your own
package you do really need to customize
your development environment you can
because this is all based on docker so
if you run g-cloud beta app
gen config custom this will generate
your configuration to deploy a custom
docker file setup this will plop a
docker file into your application
directory and what this is this is the
same docker file that we used to deploy
in the back in the background for you so
here you can see it but normally we
would actually just make this docker
file for you and it's the exact same
docker file there's no difference the
only difference here is you can see it
you can edit it you can play with it and
there shouldn't be anything hidden about
it here you can see the docker file if
you're familiar with docker
kind of inherits from this other image
on Google cloud registry called Google
App Engine Ruby latest and you can
totally find that on github that is
available in our Ruby docker repository
under Google cloud platform so that's
where it comes from
find bugs you want to file issues or
anything like that it's here and it's
totally transparent you can see this is
based off of Debian 8 at the moment and
there's a lot of useful comments
throughout so for this depend these
dependencies for example we're keeping a
list of which aptitude packages we
install and Y for which gems so that we
can keep track of those things for
ourselves and know why we added Lib curl
or something like that if you want to
know more about the Ruby runtime
including how to generate custom things
how to do all that I highly recommend
you check out the docs again I'm
pitching the docs but our Doc's for
Ruby's flex runtime are really great and
have a lot so for example we just talked
about extending the runtime you're back
at your hotel you're back home after the
conference you're exhausted you may not
remember everything from the talk again
just remember to check out the docs here
so you'll be able to find the docs for
extending the runtime right there and
other things that you'll probably need
or want when you're using Ruby on App
Engine so like how do you choose a
different version of Ruby that's really
important to answer that all we use is a
ruby version file so for any you guys
who have used urban or vm for managing
your local Ruby installations which is
very very common these days
those programs understand and use the
Ruby version file so if you're using rbn
for example and you want to walk down
your app to use Ruby 2-1 out whatever it
may be you can RBM to local - I know
it'll generate this file and then when
we Google Cloud when we g-cloud app
deploy we've read that in by default we
use one of the latest to stable versions
of Ruby for you so you don't have to
pick your own it should be good if you
choose one of the latest versions of
stable Ruby as your custom that should
be pretty fast we've got Debian packages
that we've precompiled those as binary
so those install pretty quickly when the
docker image has to build and deploy and
if not if you're picking some older or
different Ruby runtime
we haven't kind of pre-baked into the
image that's totally fine too well
actually download and compile that
version of Ruby for you and using Ruby
belt which again idiomatic all the tools
that we as Rubeus are used to using
another thing that came up I mean of
course when we made the runtime want to
make sure that when you're out boots up
it's got the environment variables that
you would expect rails on production
obvious some frameworks real on rack
ends may be a little bit less obvious
Sinatra to which I have not played with
yet uses a pen so we got feedback there
and we added that so that whatever
framework you're using hopefully Ruby
runtime will work out of the box for you
so those types of feedback we love love
to get so again check out the docs it's
great what I want to talk about next is
once you've got everything up and
running everything should be smooth
sailing from here on out you understand
how to deploy you can check out the docs
to customize things and to learn
anything else so figure out like Oh what
do you do now so there's a couple things
that I highly recommend you guys do and
you check out so first we've been
putting together a list of articles and
how-tos for how to use ruby with an on
Google cloud platform so if you go to
cloud.google.com slash ruby you'll find
things like we've got a QuickStart that
just takes like a HelloWorld Sinatra app
and walks through the steps we did to
just install the SDK she caught up to
play it go it's got everything you need
there to do it if you want to deploy
rails or if you want to deploy rails
with cloud sequel and see how to get my
sequel or Postgres cloud siegel kind of
configured and hooked up and get ready
to go and find all that there so
definitely check it out
in addition check out these Ruby flex
talks there's a lot there and not just
things that are specific to Ruby so for
example all these core app engine
concepts services versions how to do
something like like do you know how to
run something like a cron job on App
Engine once you really start using App
Engine you start to run into all these
questions what if I need to SSH into the
actual image in the actual container
that's running how can I do that all of
those things are explained here and yes
you can
so definitely dig through here and
additionally the console itself so it's
really easy to just download the CLI
deploy your app see it's up and running
and kind of walk away but I actually
highly recommend go ahead and also open
it up in the console so cloud console is
really good to click around in because
you'll discover a lot and for App Engine
for instance you'll be able to look at
all of your running instances all of
your running versions and services and
something that's specific to App Engine
it's an app engine concept are these
services and versions I'd feel bad
actually
send you guys home understanding how to
deploy something up on to App Engine and
not at least understanding one of these
additional concepts of App Engine which
are the services and versions because
they're unique and they're awesome so
when you g-cloud app deploy your
application what we actually do is we
deploy up a new version of the app and
we wait for it to go ahead and be ready
to accept new requests it's not traffic
isn't going to yet once it's ready to
serve will redirect all that traffic to
your new instance and we'll roll down
the other version cool not that exciting
but interesting but you don't have to do
it that way so one of the things that I
do all the time and you should know that
you can do too is I'll deploy a version
and I I'll tell it not to redirect all
that traffic
I can deploy my version and then I can
poke around and test it maybe you want
to run some sanity checks or you want to
run a whole regression suite on it
before you okay it for the new traffic
additionally
wrong button additionally rather than
sending all of the traffic there you
could split the traffic so one of the
things you might want to do is with this
new version start by deploying sending
1% of the traffic there watch your air
locks send 5 percent of the traffic
there watch your errors watch your logs
you can also use this for anything you
want you can use it for a be testing
deploy 5 different versions of the
application and see which one is
performing better either with your users
or actually with some performance
metrics it's really really powerful and
I want you guys to understand that
they're there but additionally services
because I didn't know this initially and
now I love them and use them all the
time when you deploy your rails app or
whatever it may be up it gets deployed
as the default service but actually
within one like App Engine application
within one project you can deploy
multiple different apps so if I for
example here's one thing I use this for
if I have a rails back-end but I also
have a node front-end it may be a couple
of other micro services one manages
authentication one manage something else
I could make five separate app engine
applications
I could make five separate projects and
so one will be a x-dot appspot.com one
would be @y and i could deploy it all
those and that's fine and that has some
benefits but if it's just a little micro
services and I want to I can actually
deploy all of those together under the
same project so it can be really really
useful again we got back to you
hopefully you're good at this point
smooth sailin you know where to find
some docs you know where to go from here
what if things don't go so well don't go
as planned you should also understand
what to do when there are problems so
you deploy this thing it's been working
great but now you deploy and you're
getting five hundreds things are
exploding what do you do
wordy where do you even go to look to
see what your application is doing where
it's breaking so this is where I'm gonna
review some of the goals
drive our tools real real quick and this
is interesting because the our team has
been working most recently on trying to
make these awesome because we're at the
point where now we really want to be
able to get in and debug these tools and
debug our apps and understand what's
going on so if you just go ahead and
after you deploy check out logging so
after you deploy your app and here we'll
just say as an example like maybe our
application logs something in case
there's an error condition and then it
explodes naive but it works for our
purposes you'll see this horrible kind
of evil page that we all see as rails
developers need to find out what went
wrong plop into logging in the cloud
console and then this is hard to see but
here I'm doing a like a full text search
to try and find this actual log and
exception this was actually the easiest
way that I could find it the logs print
out a lot of data so the stock driver
logging is really really great but I'll
show you everything they are application
sense to standard out everything that
gets sent to standard error everything
that gets written to the syslog you can
also see like the engine acts like web
logs and all of it in there is really
really great and it's got great
filtering you can filter it down to a
particular version or a particular
service but still it can be really hard
to find things and even when I do find
the line for my exception and I open it
up and I try and find my stack trace
this is my exception message I know it's
really hard to see but I open this up
and it's not immediately clear where I
can find a stack trace and now I'm
frustrated because my app is exploding
and users are telling me about it
relentlessly one of the things that I
see when I'm in here is you have the
ability to drill down these log messages
based on severity which would be great
but because by default rails is just
like this is just picking up on standard
out standard error syslog there's
nothing intelligent that we can get we
can't parse those logs really
i ibly to figure out oh this is an error
this is a d-bag debug message or an info
and we have a solution so we've been
putting together this awesome gem called
stock driver actually don't gem install
it you're not gonna want to do that put
it in your gem file so in your rails
application put gem stock driver and
that's sexually all you need put stock
driver in there redeploy it and then
your application will automatically be
sending logs and sending trace
information sending errors that get
reported but only for the stock driver
services that you enable so if you want
this go ahead you're gonna go in to
enable api's and look up all the stock
driver ones so if for some reason you
just want logs to get sent or error
reports to get sent you can do that so
going here for me I turn all these on
because they're great then once you've
got that deployed and you reproduce your
error this time I was actually going to
get a screen shot of what logging looked
like so I logged into the cloud console
to go and say like hey this is what luxe
look like now it's so much more
beautiful but instead when I logged in
the cloud console after reproducing that
error and installing the stock driver
gem this was staring me in the face at
the top of my cloud console we print out
this beautiful tile and it told me that
my welcome controllers index action just
had some runtime errors and I can click
to go and see what's there he'll send me
into error reporting and boom there it
is I can see a little mini timeline of
all my occurrences if I want to I can
click in to the exception to see what's
there and again it's gonna be really
hard to see here but for good reason
that's because it's a big stack trace so
now this is way easier and much better
information
similarly the similarly though in
logging itself the logs that get sent to
logs now that I have the stock driver
gem all of sudden the severity is
respected all of a Sun
the messages are a lot more clear just
runtime error just kaboom error log
message so just having that in there for
logs it's really really helpful as well
it'll be a lot easier for you to filter
just your fatal or your error logs which
I do a lot if your application is
getting slow open up traits when you get
in there if you've enabled it you'll see
this wonderful graph of all of your
requests that have been behaving badly
so all of your requests that are taking
500 milliseconds or more we've got one
almost a second and you can also see any
of the particularly are your eyes and
drill down but when you kind of hover
over one of these you can click on it
and see what is taking so long so
obviously this is a rails application
because you can see it's showing the
bits that are in active record how long
that's taking how long it's taking to
render the whole view the view is
obviously making some sequel calls
within it so we can see all those active
record active record active record calls
and then if you want to go even deeper
click on one of those I mean it's not
helpful to see Oh active record is
taking a long time click on one of those
and for each one of those you'll
actually get to see the exact chunk of
sequel that's getting sent to the
database and how long that's taking
stock driver debug I really really
wanted to show today this is kind of
really hot off the presses except not
off the presses yet if you guys haven't
checked out debug and seen it around
next check out the product cuz it's
really really powerful I was just
hanging out with one of our engineers he
was showing me some of what we can do
with debug and it's kind of what you
would expect in your running rails app
you can set breakpoints trigger the
breakpoint and then see locals drill
down and and put in expressions to see
exactly what variables were in what
state and even some really cool local
debugging which seemed really really
magical and I'm excited for us so watch
this space that stackdriver
definitely installed in your app for
when things go poorly you're gonna want
it I usually
ploy my application stop engine I do
this all time it works great then it
blows up and I say Remy why didn't you
had stuck driver again and then I do
when I read the play um we looked at the
run time again we'll check out the docs
and stuff for that I talked a little bit
about what the team is doing so I want
to leave you here again with some of the
resources that you can use to go out
there get back to your hotel and get
back to work to go ahead and play with
this because please do first off
everything's up on github so under the
Google cloud platform organization on
github you'll find all kinds of awesome
projects submit issues send us feedback
we really wanted and we really respond
to it and again the people who have been
communicating with us have been so so
great and it makes our experience a lot
better - knowing you're out there and
knowing that we can solve your problems
check out the App Engine flex talks
search for those pull them up it'll be
really helpful for those client
libraries that we looked at because
they're so cool remember to go pull up
one of these little client library pages
it has all of the links you need to get
up and running and finally check out
cloud aqua lock home slash Ruby we're
continually adding new information
they're new articles new how to's new
links to code samples and we're really
trying to give this some love that's
actually all I have for you guys today I
want to thank you guys so much we do
have some time we have almost ten
minutes so if anybody has some questions
I'd love to take them
[Applause]
[Music]
you